sie sind 50 jahre alt sie haben keine
besonderen krankheiten ein schlaganfall
vor fünf jahren
sie nehmen medikamente ja
isabel i do arbeitet im gesundheitswesen
aber hier im uniklinikum von oc geht es
heute um sie wegen ihrer arbeit und
ihres alters kann sie gegen cupid
geimpft werden
ich bin entspannt sehr entstand können
sie den menschen die das nicht sind
wegen der impfung die zögern in der
familie ja und warum es ist ein neuer
impfstoff spannung in den familien und
dem ganzen land die impfkampagne hat
begonnen für die verantwortlichen hier
zu langsam
nach der erfahrung der impfkampagne 2009
gegen die schweinegrippe h1n1 hat die
regierung gezögert sich gegen die
menschen zu stellen die nicht an die
impfung glauben
2009 hatte die regierung fast 100
millionen dosen impfstoff gegen die
schweinegrippe angeschafft aber nur vier
millionen menschen ließen sich am ende
impfen ein teures scheitern
seither ist misstrauen gegen impfungen
und staatliche autorität in
gesundheitsfragen weiter verbreitet als
anderswo
und das im land von louis pasteur einem
der miterfinder moderne impfungen heute
schüren impfgegner angst gegen das
coebad aktie
es wird genetisches material massiv in
den körper gespritzt
das geht dann in die zellen
was passiert dort es wird antikörper
geben aber sicher nicht nur wird es das
erbmaterial beeinflussen diese pseudo
dokumentation hat in frankreich ein
millionen publikum gefunden corona
impfung politik pharmaindustrie ein
verschwörungs geraune dass die regierung
unter druck setzt
die regierung hatte angst die impfgegner
zu brüskieren
in frankreich ist das eine recht große
gruppe tatsächlich widerspricht die
regierung dem nicht einmal wir müssen
zunächst alte menschen in heimen so dass
diese sich nicht fortbewegen müssen
das dauert erst mal etwas länger aber
das nehme ich in kauf es braucht zeit
für erklärungen und überzeugungsarbeit
wir legen wert auf eine
einverständniserklärung bevor jemand
geimpft
hallo ich bin's dr della croce tier
ich komme wegen der impfung darf ich mir
ich einen moment zu ihnen setzen
frankreichs regierung schrieb ein
ausführliches vorgespräch mit einer
ärztin oder einem arzt vor das sollte
skeptiker und bevölkerung beruhigen
kostete aber zeit als man in deutschland
schon 100 200.000 menschen geimpft hatte
waren es hier 200 oder 500 das war
lächerlich
wir hatten das gefühl wir sind die
letzte in europa anfangs gab es nicht
einmal amtliche informationen über den
stand der impfungen einen blogger trug
sie zusammen
während der ersten woche gab es keine
offizielle datenbank in der die
geimpften personen erfasst wurden die
regierung musste die daten gewissermaßen
mit der hand einsammeln
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister
werfen der regierung vor sich auf die
falschen konzentriert zu haben
es ist ein fehler die kampagne so
gestartet zu haben dass man die
skeptiker nicht so sehr verschreckt man
hätte sich besser auf die vielen
menschen stützen sollen die sich sehr
wohl impfen lassen wollten
doch statt auf bürgermeister zu hören
setzte die regierung auf eine politik
von oben
frankreich ist ein ultra
zentralistisches land und beim krisen
management besonders im elysée beim
präsidenten und premierminister
das hat für ein unwohlsein gesorgt den
eindruck man sei schlecht organisiert
das zögern und zaudern hat die
diskussion um die impfung nicht beendet
sondern weiter angeheizt auch in ossi
es ist bedauerlich dass so viele angst
haben
das ist keine angst sie sind unsicher
ich habe keine lust mich impfen zu
lassen
warum nicht das ist nicht ausgereift
bei aids hat man in 30 jahren keinen
impfstoff gefunden und hierbei corvette
wie durch zufall in so kurzer zeit
schneller als die impfungen kommt das
virus voran in immer mehr die partners
und städten wie neu sie wird die
nächtliche sperrstunde vorgezogen um 18
uhr endet das öffentliche leben
[Musik]
langsame impfstart verprellte
bürgermeister im parlament verteidigt
sich die regierung und weiß die
verantwortung von sich aus
nachgeordneten stellen
nun wir fahren nicht auf sicht die
strategie wurde festgelegt von der
gesundheitsbehörde die daran erinnere
ich eine unabhängige behörde ist
ungeduld macht sich breit der
bürgermeister von nancy prescht vor er
kündigt heute im fernsehen an
es könnten sich ab sofort auch menschen
dort impfen lassen die die
zentralregierung bisher nicht zugelassen
hatte das ziel ist 20.000 menschen zu
erreichen die über 75 cent und zu hause
leben in ossi
das würde die impfungen beschleunigen
mehr tempo verspricht nun auch die
regierung bis ende januar sollen eine
million menschen geimpft werden
das würde zeit denn gerade erwägt die
regierung wegen steigender
infektionszahlen eine dritte allgemeine
ausgangssperre in frankreich zu
verhängen